and they just helped themselves to his
stripper then I could do hello I'm
Jeremy Clarkson I'm here
unpaid automate an absolutely plain
doesn't make you interesting it doesn't
make different to officer some life
advice for you've got some questions
here people would like answering this
Dan from South End the ones told me to
bugger off when I ask for his autograph
I have a two day rule when it comes to
wearing boxer shorts I've been told
that's unacceptable what do you think
what if you're a child it's like riding
a bicycle interestingly I once worked
with a cameraman who claimed he pinned a
stretcher pair of boxer shorts out for
five days great enjoy yourself you know
obviously there was the back-to-front on
day two inside out day three inside out
and back to front day four and then he
had the fifth one we don't know what it
was come in handy a couple of times I've
recently been wearing my girlfriend's
long as it's been so warm lately do you
think this is the start of something
more profound Tim from stains yes I do
know don't smoke and as we'll talk about
yeah I think this is from JB who's from
Norfolk someone told me that my ass look
like the back of a Ford cat is that a
compliment
can you shed any light you what car does
look like a teapot so what they're
saying is you've got an ass that looks
like a teapot sure that's not
necessarily a bad thing
I like a French cloth that's all that
matters this from Drew in something in
the bar that I work at they say French
is the language of love do you know any
phrases I can try my luck at with her
well you could try a mountain or Thomas
you know wait a minute lick less yet so
you'd get that wrong right a metonym Tom
last year and now like the dog it's the
only French in here the guy I've just
started dating pick me up last week at
his car for the first time it's a Fiat
500 should I be worried well Natalie
from Manchester no knee shouldn't there
is nothing wrong with the Fiat 500
unless it's the convertible model oh gee
they really rally from Blackpool and
planning a stag do from a mate but
everyone's dropping out like flies how
do I explain the distinctive 15 is going
to be more like a stag do a five that
could be worse I once organized a stag
do there for a friend of mine and he
didn't turn up and I had to explain to
all of his guests that the groom wasn't
there and they just helped themselves to
his stripper then I couldn't do and
there we are those those are the the
readers questions and the viewers
questions I should say that's what my
aides coming through newspaper training
I hope I've been of some help
[Music]